china has the world's toughest kovid 19
restrictions in place
and with these latest outbreaks we're
seeing police in white hazmat suits
panic buying and shops advice to work
from home just like 2020 all over again
so why is china struggling with corona
virus
it's all to do with china's
controversial dynamic zero covered
policy essentially instead of learning
to live with a virus like many other
countries china wants to stamp out any
outbreaks as soon as they start
but with the far more infectious omicron
variant this is proving difficult and
leading to extreme measures
tens of millions of people have been put
into lockdown across china
nowhere is this more felt than in
shanghai where many of the city's 26
million people have been forced to stay
at home fences have been erected around
infected housing blocks and streets
some residents have protested from their
balconies and videos like this show
desperate people trying to pull the
fences down
shanghai is doing daily city-wide cover
tests and positive cases are put into
quarantine centers where living
conditions are tough
for places affected by outbreaks like
shanghai the main policies of xero kovid
are restricting travel in and out of the
region regular community testing
programs the closures of non-essential
businesses and the suspension of schools
and public transport
there are currently dozens of cities
with some form of these rules in place
the rate of covert 19 is rising in china
but compared to some places like the uk
it remains relatively low as of april 27
2022 china has reported 3.2 deaths per
million people while the uk has 2
544 deaths per million
china has in general dealt with kovid
pretty well
reported infections and deaths have been
very low throughout the pandemic with
the country recording around 4 600
deaths from covert 19 since 2019.
they even hosted the winter olympics
without experiencing a major outbreak
but now things are getting worse
omicron is significantly more infectious
than previous covert strains limited
targeted lockdowns work for china before
but because of omicron these outbreaks
are getting out of control china has
fully vaccinated around 88 of its
population with a massive 11.5 billion
doses given out
but those are all homegrown chinese
vaccines less effective than western
mrna jabs which china has refused to use
many elderly vulnerable people have not
even been fully vaccinated china's
intensive care system is underdeveloped
and not ready to deal with a massive
wave of admissions
all that means more serious cases of
covert 19 and more lockdowns
[Music]
some of this is science but much of it
is politics chinese officials have spent
the pandemic loudly criticizing western
democracy's handling of coven 19 saying
dynamic coveted zero points to the
superiority of the chinese system
reversing from that is very difficult so
this isn't just a public health policy
it's political ideology and that means
this is going to be live for people here
for a long while to come